- What was the occasion here?
I love this dress so much.
This is so pretty.
- [Gwen] That's Ken Nina.
- Wow.
- Thank you.
- The designer is Janina.
That was my first public date
with Blake Shelton actually.
(audience cheering)
- I didn't know that.
- It was.
- I love that.
- And that was, it was the
Oscars Vanity Fair Party.
I think I played at the
party and then we went
out that night, so it was
like he never does red carpets
now that I know him, yeah,
that was like, we got,
I think we did a red carpet.
It was kind of a red carpet.
It was raining that night
and yeah, so always,
that melts me when I see it
because it's such a memory for me.
A good one.
- I didn't know that.
But you look like Christopher Lady in Red.
You're walking in the room
and the song was written for you.
Like that song back in the day.
I just, just aged myself.
I love that song so much.
Okay, so wait, where was this shot taken?
What about this one?
Gorgeous.
- Okay, that's, thank
you, that's Vera Wang.
It was at the Met Ball this
year and she's just so talented.
Vera's been doing it for so
long and so to be able to work
with her, it was just amazing
to wear a couture dress made
for me.
When the sketch came, it
was like, it looked exactly
like that.
They drew my face, the hair, everything.
It was weird to go from
a sketch to real life.
And that was one of
those crazy moments where
I was gonna have a makeup
artist do my makeup
and she had her mom had an
emergency and she had to leave.
So I luckily had my makeup
bag and did my own makeup
that night.
So it was one of those like crazy moments.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
- It was exciting, but.
- I see another difference
between, I see you came
out looking like that
after you did your makeup.
Would've been very different for me.
- I want to do your makeup.
- I let you, anyone can 'cause I don't.